- Hey, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
All right, through a couple of these.
All right, so I wanna do two things today.
I wanna talk about
how you can take your
AI-assisted development
and use Slack to supercharge that,
to streamline it,
and I also want to touch upon
how you can use Slack to
deploy agents and build AI.
So, I'll try to go over some
high-level topics when I can.
I don't know.
Actually, who in this room uses Slack?
In the room, in this box
area that uses Slack?
Okay, has anyone
developed on Slack before?
Okay, one or two.
Okay, okay, so I'll go over some,
like I'll try to sneak into
my high-level concepts.
All right, so Slack,
the Slack platform came
out maybe 8-10 years ago,
and at its core,
it's basically an
event-driven platform, right?
Just like Slack, the products.
So back then we called them bots, right?
Bots were just basically non-human actors
within the Slack workspace.
And now we call them agents,
which are bots with LLMs attached.
But technology and the architecture
is almost exactly the same.
So the past few years,
we've found a really good match
with the development
that's been happening.
So, it's really kinda a
natural match of Slack
and between a lot of the explosions.
So, I wanna focus on the far right here.
I'm not gonna talk about Slack usage,
I'm gonna really focus
on developer conference,
so we'll focus on AI specifically
and what we're doing within Slack.
You know, so every company is complex.
You know, there's no one silver bullet,
one solution that works.
You know, you acquire
companies, make acquisitions,
they have employees
build things and leave.
You're working.
There's always a blend of solutions,
so our approach to AI is
trying to support all of that.
You know, whether it's out of the box,
whether it's something
that you've had running
on your servers for 10 years,
whether it's a partner that
you chose to work with.
So, we try to build in a way
and give you the tools,
be able to serve all those things
because really, I'm sure all
the businesses you work for
use all that.
So, I would say our biggest
advantage is the UI.
So, when you're developing AI,
you should be focused on what?
The new technology, the
business value, the solution.
Slack gives you an out-of-the-box UI
you don't have to worry about.
We've introduced some
new things this year.
So, if you've seen work objects,
we are having some new multimodal
stuff that's coming out.
And then probably one of
the most popular aspects
of working in Slack and
building AI is context, right?
So to have a good agent,
what you need is who's talking to who?
What are the relationships?
How do people relate to each other?
Channels relate to each other,
objects relate to each other.
What happened last week?
And also what happened
in the last five minutes?
So, oftentimes though,
that's what it takes
to have a good contextual agent
that actually makes sense,
that actually serves a purpose.
So, we give that to you
through a set of APIs
we can call in real time,
you can call on behalf
of the user as well.
So, when you're launching
agents in the Slack,
you can understand what
that user is allowed to see
and only what that user is allowed to see,
and then use that context for the agent.
So, we also launched this
year some automation.
So, like I mentioned,
every company's different.
Sometimes you don't wanna build, right?
So you just wanna be able
to do no code or configure.
So, and that's the case,
you can also automate that in Slack.
And then, lastly what
we've been trying to do
is take all these new UI elements
you see around the internet on
different AI products you use
and blend them into a Slack platform,
but do it in a way that doesn't
increase developer load,
it doesn't take any like
cognitive work to do.
So, we put in streaming,
Shimmer states, thinking strings,
things like that kind of
naturally into the platform.
But we've done it in ways
that allows you to develop very quickly.
So, I wanna bring over,
I'm gonna run a demo here,
and what I wanna show you
is how you can use some
tools you might use today
when you're developing
with AI within Slack.
All right, so I'm gonna talk through this.
Well, this is Slack if
you haven't seen it.
What we have here is a payments channel.
This is a group of developers
working on a payments app, right?
So, GitHub is in here.
In your Slack, you probably
have many different apps
and bots sending messages,
so this may seem familiar to you.
But in addition to GitHub,
what we also have is a Copilot agent.
So, launching agents in the
Slack is essentially native.
We've had the capability for a while,
we've matured it,
but it just comes
out-of-the-box functionality.
So, in this example,
let's say there's an issue
and I want to invoke an
agent that's in this channel.
So, what I'm gonna do is call
up the GitHub Copilot agent
from this action field,
and just call it like I'm
calling another human, right?
There's actually six different
agents in this channel,
but I'm just gonna call GitHub Copilot.
And what it's gonna do
is it's gonna take off,
it's gonna say, "All
right, I have a job to do,
I'm gonna do it."
You might see some emojis being used.
So I think it'll say, "Yep,"
I have some eyes, I'm looking at this.
So, I know there are eight
people in this channel.
Your channels may have 1,000,
you may have five,
but typically you want
everyone in the channel
to understand that something's happening
and I don't have to do anything,
and then the one person being
able to do that thing, right?
That's probably the most
efficient way to work.
So, what Copilot will do
is automatically let your team know,
"Yep, this is being looked at,
being taken care of."
We've went ahead and created a PR,
you can look in the web as well,
and then it'll use some
of our new UI elements
to just update the progress along the way,
which is pretty cool.
So, if you've used Copilot before
or Cursor, Codex,
this will look very familiar to you.
You can see your running agents.
So, we always try to give you the ability
to deep link exactly where you need to go
in case you want to go
do some deep, deep work
outside of Slack, right?
Because sometimes that's
the best place to do it.
So if you really wanna see
if there's different processes running,
you can go ahead and deep link there.
And then this PR essentially
will just be updated over time.
I think overall it's gonna
do maybe three commits
and then Copilot will just do its thing.
Again, we'll deep link for the
people that need to go out.
And the best part of bringing
the AI development into Slack
is it's becoming more and
more asynchronous, right?
No one wants to sit there
and stare at their computer
and watch it work.
So, when you're in Slack,
it'll just give you a notification
when it's done, right?
If you wanna go check,
you can see what it's doing, great,
or you can go about your day
and your little activity monitor
will pop up when it's done.
I wanna point out a couple other things.
So, in this one channel,
we also, I think there's six agents total.
We have some other agents here.
We have Claude, Codex, Cursor.
Does anyone use Cursor?
Okay. Anyone?
Oh, that guy does.
Anyone use Codex or Claude?
Okay, okay.
All right, so maybe most are on Claude.
So, all these agents are
in that channel as well,
and you can call them
in the exact same way.
So, that's an interesting
distribution though.
In addition to that, we have
some out-of-the-box agents.
So, oftentimes, if you don't wanna build,
you just want to use Salesforce agents,
we have that, we have those as well,
and those are gonna be
under the Agents tab.
And what those are really useful for
is saving your team time.
So Channel Expert is one
that we came out with
earlier this year.
You know, I'm sure everyone
in this room has had channels
where people drop in and ask questions.
Maybe they're good questions,
maybe they're bad questions,
but they're definitely
distracting questions, right?
So what the Channel Expert does
is it automatically looks
back to through the channel,
also looks at any resources
that you choose to give it access to,
you can just click and add to it,
and it'll go ahead and try
to answer those questions.
So, it's great for people
that aren't on your team.
Maybe it's great for you
if you came back from vacation,
you're like, "All right, what happened?"
Or maybe there's like, "Oh, has
this issue happened before?"
It's just a little value add.
I use it in all my channels.
It's great.
If someone asks something,
there's a very good chance
that they can get that answer
through those resources
or the past 500, 1,000 messages
or pings that came into that channel,
so that's cool.
And Employee Agent's a fun one too
because this channel's called payment-pr,
every once in a while you
might get someone pop in
and be like, "Oh, my re:Invent
expense was rejected,"
which obviously the development
team would not support that,
so this agent would kick in
and be like, "All right, no, no,
here are the company resources,
like you want to go here to
ask accounting about this."
So, yeah, having all those within,
I mean, maybe you wouldn't
have six within one channel,
this is obviously for
demonstration purposes,
but you can,
and they can live there in harmony.
So, looking over here,
we have the plan.
So, the agent is saying,
you know, "This is what I'm gonna do,
this is how I'm doing it,
and it'll update you along the way."
At the end, it'll clean
all this up actually,
so it'll just have a nice message.
This, it says in progress,
I think it's okay, so it's done.
And what you can do,
you can also open up in VS Code.
So really the whole goal
is to let the people
find what they need to find,
let everyone else know
things are happening,
cut down in communication.
Okay, so we're back here.
Obviously, this is a
extremely simple solve.
This isn't a really
complex agentics solution,
but it did solve it.
It created a PR.
I went there.
So, if I close here
and I go over to the actual PR,
the other thing that happens
is I might be over here,
I might be reviewing it,
maybe it takes five minutes,
maybe it takes two weeks.
But because that agent
is over in the channel,
whatever I do in here is
automatically gonna reflect
so my other teammates can see.
What's interesting about that
is it also shows up in Search, right?
So, for incidents that pop up,
when you're using Slack Search,
you're searching in Slackbot,
all of this data will now pop up,
be like, "Oh, that incident
actually resolved."
That just happens automatically
for everyone in the company,
which I think is really interesting.
So, not best practices,
no comment,
merge obviously not the best thing to do,
but you can see it
actually keeps it updated.
You can see the history of the issue
and then actually resolution.
So, pretty interesting.
All right, I think that's done.
Let me pop over here.
All right, so I showed you a couple,
we launched probably hundreds this year.
Slack platform is always free.
There's no, you can just install apps,
you don't have to worry about it.
If you're paying these companies,
we wanna make sure you get
the most value out of that.
So, if you go over the Slack Marketplace,
you can click to install
and add them to Slack,
so I encourage you to
check that out after this.
Okay, so shifting more to, say,
from AI-assisted development
to actually building agents in Slack.
So, this is good
because I think most of you
hadn't built on Slack before.
So, what is the Slack app?
Like I said before, Slack is,
it's an event-based platform, right?
Essentially an app is
something that sits over here,
receives events and sends events back.
I mean, it's not something
you configure on Slack,
so we're language agnostic.
I do wanna call one
really cool thing though,
which helps getting some,
takes zero in our world
from like hours to minutes,
and that's the ability to use web sockets.
So, when you launch a local Slack app,
you can use our CLI
many of you probably use vibe
code now or AI assist code,
that works well too.
You can actually run it in Socket Mode,
so you don't have to worry
about setting up an endpoint,
you don't have to worry
about getting approval
to set up this static
endpoint for events to go to.
You can actually run it
right away within seconds
and have that work in Slack.
In that scenario, hopefully
you're starting in a sandbox,
but then when you go to production,
you have the option to
keep it in Socket Mode
or set up a static endpoint.
So you always have that option,
and when you're building for a company,
it's a really nice option to have.
I don't know if anyone's
ever been to those arguments
trying to open up an endpoint before,
but it can kill a project
extremely quickly.
So, there's a couple
concepts in Slack with OAuth,
I guess they're not that unique,
but when you install a Slack app,
we have the bot or the agent,
then we also have the
ability to authenticate
each individual user,
which is more and more popular these days.
So, I mentioned earlier
how you can get the context for that user,
you can take actions
on behalf of that user,
you can search,
you can understand who they talk to,
what they talk about,
how things relate in
their life within Slack.
You can pull all that in through our APIs,
and it's just a simple, simple OAuth,
you can get that through the user,
so that's a really
important topic as well.
All right, let me come back over here.
And I thought about showing you,
I don't know, some complex ways to build
and getting deeper,
but frankly, like if I
was gonna build on Slack
and I was gonna launch an agent,
this is what I would probably do,
so I just thought it would
show the simplest possible way.
So, this is Cursor.
If you use Cursor, you recognize it.
But basically, in the past 10 years,
Slack, we've made a lot
of hard choices, right?
It's incredibly simple to
make a complex platform.
You just say yes to everything.
Like, "Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes."
You have this incredibly complex cap form.
It takes you 18 months
to learn to configure.
You need a PhD to even
like enter this space.
We've always taken the opposite approach.
Like, "No, we wanna be simple,
straightforward, easy to use.
We want you to be able to build
an app in less than an hour.
We want it to be quick."
And it's paying dividends now
because it, it lends itself
very, very, very well
to AI assist or vibe coding.
So when you plug your tools against Slack,
I mean, this is using
a simple one-paragraph,
maybe two-sentence prompt
saying, "Build me an assistant-like agent
using public Slack docs and go nuts."
You know, it's searching the web,
there's a couple tools,
but I'm just kind of letting it run,
and it's obviously
running it fast forward,
but I think when I recorded it,
it took six, seven minutes,
and at the end you get a
fully functioning Slack app
with one paragraph.
So, I mean that's probably
the biggest advantage
of our platform
is just that simplicity, right?
The ability to just try it out
because when you're building,
I mean, I don't know how
many people in this room
have built something
that's in POC purgatory,
probably everyone.
I have, like most of my
stuff is in POC purgatory,
I would say.
So, I mean, really the
advantage to this quick approach
is you get it in users' hands, right?
Something might seem
incredible in your mind,
and might be like,
you think you're like carrying everything,
but as you get user's hands,
like, "Yeah, that's not that sweet."
So being able to actually launch
and test quickly is critical, right?
You might fail 99 times out of 100
when we're on like the
frontier of building agents,
trying new solutions.
So being able to actually do
it this quickly and launch,
I think it's critical.
I mean, and one thing I
always caution against
is spending six months with a plan,
building big architecture
because everything
changed since then, right?
Just get it in someone's hands,
start testing.
Yeah, so I just gave it that one prompt
and that is an installable Slack app.
You could run that by run and Socket Mode
and it's in your Slack workspace.
You don't have to do anything else.
So, back over here.
Okay.
All right, so I wanna
open up to some questions.
What do you...
Questions about Slack, about AI,
about agents, about tools you use?
Anything?
Anything I talked about?
What do you? Anyone got anything?
No? All right.
No one? Okay.
Okay, well, check us out over 840.
I don't...
It's that way.
It's like if you see actually,
if you see Red Hat, it's past that.
So, if you wanna come by,
we can show you how to build,
talk through solutions,
work with you on whatever.
Yeah, thank you.